this is the saddest story there have
been a lot of sad stories recently this
is one of the saddest stories I've seen
recently
comes from McDonald's I actually this
was really weird timing because the
story just broke today but last night
was it last night I think it was
or two nights ago I was I was getting
back from a speech it was two nights ago
I'm getting back from a speech
and
I I arrived late I hadn't had dinner and
I say okay I'm getting a little Mac
attack right now I want to get a little
Double Quarter Pounder with cheese
before I get home it's late Elise has
already had her dinner plus I can sneak
a little fast food you know and Lisa's
not looking okay great so I pull up and
I see this weird thing on the menu at
McDonald's it says it's a
I forget what they called it it was some
weird co-branding thing and it looked it
looked like a Happy Meal but it was
clearly for adults and it said limited
edition but it was that little box you
know you used to get for the Happy Meals
I said I don't know whatever ordered my
quarter pounder with cheese went home
had a nice night
I find out today McDonald's is launching
happy meals for adults
they say quote we're taking one of the
most nostalgic McDonald's experiences
and literally repackaging it in a way
literally people use that word literally
way too much repackaging it in a new way
that's hyper relevant for our adult fans
McDonald's USA Chief marketing and
customer experience officer Tariq Hassan
said in a press release everyone
remembers their first Happy Meal as a
kid and they can't sit still feeling as
you dug in to see what was inside that
little red box could turn a regular
Tuesday into the best day ever and now
we're reimagining that experience in a
whole new way this time for adults so
what does it come with it's in a box
similar kind of box and you open it up
instead of the tiny little cheeseburger
it's a Big Mac because you're supposed
to be an adult now and instead of the
tiny little drink it's a big size drink
instead of the tiny little fries it's
bigger fries
and there's a toy
there it comes with a toy
because you're an adult but you're an
estate you're going to go back and
relive that exp this is so sad
man my generation is so freaking sad
it's the Millennials are just it's just
pathetic
because this generation just won't grow
up
yeah I like nostalgic things yeah when I
think of the 90s that well that was fun
90s fashion and boy it was nice being a
kid in some ways although don't forget
nostalgia's history after a few drinks
okay wasn't really the way you remember
it but okay
why do I need to pretend to be a kid
again
why are why do Millennials just why
won't Millennials grow
up grow up get married have kids get a
normal job
grow up man oh my gosh well come on
Michael don't be such a downer you know
it's fun to relive your childhood you
know the crazy part I agree with that
it is fun to relive your childhood do
you know how you relive your childhood
in a normal way you have kids and then
do things with them it's so it saddens
me so much
when I see my fellow Millennials going
to Disney World
alone
not with kids not even forget let's say
they can't have their own kids not even
with their nieces or nephews or no not
nothing they go alone and they go on the
rides themselves they're in their 30s
and then they go
what do they do they go and get the
Happy Meal and they they try to collect
all the little toys so they can put the
toys next to their other toy collection
in their overgrown child dystopia guys
grow up man growing up is good
I know we all have this Nostalgia for
our past let me tell you something
barring you know certain years people
have bad things happen traumas and
things but if you just I'm saying year
over year I think my life has gotten
better every single year of my life I
love it I look forward to the future I
do not fear getting old I love it I look
I want to see my kids grow up I wanna I
wanna continue to do work that I find
important and that I want to build a
life with my family I don't want to
return to the freaking playpen and play
with little Grimace toys and and suck on
my Happy Meal
slurp up a little you know Coca-Cola and
eat a cheeseburger okay it's you can do
it with your kids it's this it reminds
me of that song by Kenny Loggins you
know do you know the song pook back to
Pooh Corner so help me if you can I've
gotta get back it's this whole thing
about he wrote it when he was graduating
high school how he was lost in the woods
and he's got to get back to Pooh Corner
and what happened to Winnie the Pooh and
all of his friends I can't find them
anymore and he's coming to terms with
leaving childhood and graduating high
school and moving on and becoming an
adult
he says I just want to get back to Pooh
Corner but I can't because that's over
now I'm going a little further today
than I thought I could and all right I'm
out of here right but then he revisits
the song he writes after he had a kid he
he writes another stanza and he says you
know
I have made it back to Pooh Corner
because I'm looking at my son right now
playing with my old little toys
but we can't we don't do that as
Millennials it's just it's this
generation of completely stunted growth
and it's really sad and I I don't know
why was it a failure of our parents sure
blame your parents is it a failure of
the economy okay blame the economy is it
a failure of this everybody else's fault
other than you're on okay fine blame
whoever you want I'm just telling you
guys oh I'm preaching to the choir with
you but I'm telling the people who are
getting the adult happy meal
growing up is good it's good I know it's
scary and I know you don't don't gosh if
I get married then I won't be able to
sleep with everyone else you're right oh
gosh if I have kids I'll I'll have to be
accountable and responsible yes you will
oh that's scary yeah it's scary it's
worth it growing up is worth it when I
was a child I ate Happy Meals when I
became an adult I put away childish
things and I bought happy meals for my
little kid okay
and for me I buy Double Quarter Pounders
with cheese okay the rest of the show is
continuing now you do not want to miss
it we've got fake headlines
we've got the real headlines from the
week there's one fake headline in there
the producers have sent these to me you
have to guess and then I have to guess
which the fake headline is I've been on
a roll so far we will see uh how it is
going over at the member block see you
there
[Music]
[Music]